the kids that i don't know how the paul
brothers did in school
but they're doing fine jake paul's doing
fine
he's got an arsenal
fbi removes firearms from jake paul's
mansion in probe of shopping mall ryan
i commend him i go the other way i say
get more guns jake
get a nuke get some chemical weapons
start experimenting manipulating bat
coronaviruses
that seems to have worked i say go big
la's gonna fall all my friends like
whitney cummings and joe rogan they're
gonna be out of here
i need to ingratiate myself with these
people because they're gonna have a
compound and an arsenal
don't you need someone to make you laugh
jake you got a harem of women you got
enough people to film you
but you're going to need a jester a
court jester let me walk around your
calabasas mansion
and be a goofball you can throw things
at me break eggs on my head
and when the city falls i will be behind
the walls
with you and the rpgs that you own
yes or yes please please god help me
i can't be here when the city crumbles
the only people that are going to be
able to defend themselves when the end
comes are youtubers and tick-tockers
charlie dimiglio's gonna have a house
with a moat with alligators in it
if you get too close they're gonna burn
you alive they're gonna torch you
so i just need to get in with these
people for christ
god what's wrong
he made one mistake he left a rifle by
the hot tub
and some rat some rat informed on him
no good i will enforce loyalty
i will be the jester i will i will make
you laugh
i just want to know that when the end
comes
i will be behind the gates behind the
walls
and i will be protected by your
considerable arsenal and i think we
should start expanding quite frankly
i don't think we should only have guns i
think we should experiment
with a small bio weapons lab on the
property you have the space
you have the spaces calabasas you have
the space let's do a small bio weapons
lab
why not i hope he has that i hope he has
a hydrogen bomb
he deserves it because he didn't listen
to teachers who told him to read his
books
and not go on youtube
he went on the internet he said i want
to live in a big house with a lot of
guns
and i want to rap if i want and do i rap
it doesn't matter anyway
does anyone even do anything anymore
nothing matters
our president was a game show host you
can be whatever you want to be now you
can be versatile
all these tick-tock girls just have
these auto-tuned songs and the whole
song is like
i'm sad i get that other people get that
where's that i'm sad you're sad
doesn't matter they can't [ __ ] sing
can you do an auto tune
on my voice uh in post i can yeah if you
want to sing right now
you're sad i get tired we all get
fine sometimes i think i'm happy but i'm
sad
if millions of dollars they're sad all
the time
but it doesn't matter so i commend him
and i want to join forces with him in
his
what i imagine the fbi is calling it
loosely a loosely formed militia
i don't know
what what even happened to this guy what
do you have a bunch of guns
they took the guns yeah they just
checked his guns yeah
he needs guns yeah he does the guy needs
guns he's done well
i'm just offering my services here as
somebody that could commit to the
operation
yeah i like that i like this this is
when he got in trouble for the mall
thing he goes
i'm above that he said i don't need to
vandalize i don't need to loot i know
it's not the way forward
again that's like a better position than
joe biden
why does jake paul have a better
position why can't joe biden say that
why can't joe biden say yeah chaos and
violence is not the way far why is jake
paul
making more sense than joe biden
can joe biden say that can joe biden
come out and say anything publicly
is he alive do you want to lose again